[Música]
ucrania asegura haber recuperado seis
mil kilómetros cuadrados de territorio
controlado por los rusos así lo afirmó
el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski la contraofensiva que comenzó a
inicios de septiembre está teniendo
impactos en el poder interno que tiene
vladimir putin en rusia
escocia despide a la reina isabel
segunda hoy su féretro fue trasladado
del palacio real de holyroodhouse
hasta la catedral de san ginés donde se
mantendrá se mantendrá en capilla
ardiente durante 24 horas antes de ser
trasladado a londres además el nuevo
monarca el rey carlos tercero se reunió
con el parlamento escocés
activistas en pro de los derechos
humanos en afganistán quieren que el
país y en particular la situación de las
mujeres vuelvan al centro de las
discusiones de la asamblea general de la
onu y la sesión número 77 comenzará el
martes con la posición del nuevo
presidente de la asamblea
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
informativa de france 24
yo soy maría clara calle y es un placer
acompañarlos comenzamos en ucrania el
presidente de volodymyr selenski afirmó
que sus tropas recuperaron cerca de
6.000 kilómetros cuadrados en la región
de jarquín desde principios de mes
recordemos que ucrania lanzó una
contraofensiva desde el 6 de septiembre
para recuperar el poder en el noreste
del país y también en el sur en la
región de gerzón además los ucranianos
están a punto de retomar el poder en la
ciudad norteña decisión lo que sería su
logro más importante desde que vencieron
a los rusos en la región capital de kiev
esto fue lo que dijo el ex ido desde los
primeros días de septiembre y hasta hoy
nuestros guerreros han liberado más de
6000 kilómetros cuadrados del territorio
de ucrania en el sur y el este los
avances de nuestras fuerzas continúan
por 12
previamente hablábamos con la llosa de
analista de relaciones internacionales y
estudios estratégicos de fuerzas
terrestres navales aéreas y espaciales
rusas desde san juan puerto rico nos
explicó por qué es relevante el éxito el
avance ucraniano
bueno demuestran que ha sido un fracaso
al menos en su objetivo principal que
había sido tratar de copar de invadir en
febrero a toda ucrania en pocos días eso
pues se vio ya desde los primeros meses
que era imposible y ahora a pesar de los
avances que moscú había logrado en el
lugar y en donges por ejemplo pues hay
esta contraofensiva
al norte norte y noreste de harkov que
ha logrado empujar a los rusos y parece
que los rusos se han agotado no tienen
digamos que la fuerza
digamos que el equipo la motivación la
moral para seguir adelante parece como
que se han empantanado así que es muy
relevante porque la ucrania con las
fuerzas occidentales la tecnología el
armamento que occidente le está dando y
su entrenamiento también cómo usar
adecuadamente ese equipo están logrando
empujar rusos y probablemente no se va a
quedar allí el objetivo de ucrania es
liberar todo su territorio incluyendo la
crimea aunque tome tiempo pero este esta
contraofensiva no sólo por hardcore pero
también los avances aunque lentos al sur
y por gerson está demostrando que rusia
ahora está en una fase de defensiva y
habrá que ver si logra recuperar la una
y la iniciativa pero da la impresión que
ahora la iniciativa la tiene ucrania
además esta contraofensiva ucraniana
estaba afectando un poco al poder
político que tiene el presidente ruso
vladimir putin al interior del país
algunos actores están profundizando su
oposición y por ejemplo le pidieron al
parlamento estatal que presente
acusaciones de traición contra putin
para destituirlo de su cargo la llosa si
nos explico si tiene o no futuro esta
solicitud
bueno en el momento de la impresión que
putin está firmemente en el poder por el
apoyo de los servicios de inteligencia
de la fsb servicio de seguridad federal
y que podría estar también dominando a
las fuerzas armadas o sea que no habría
posibilidades aparentes de un golpe
contra putin en ese sentido y son tropas
procesos profesionales o generales que
no estarían al menos de momento- 12b en
pos de un alzamiento de un golpe pero no
se puede descartar si sigue digamos que
una guerra que el tiempo va en contra de
putin mientras más larga sea esta guerra
más va a sufrir su base de poder más va
a sufrir la economía rusa y más derrotas
probablemente va a recibir puede
intentar quitar la tarjeta la baraja de
armas nucleares tácticas podría ser
capaz pero eso implicará una reacción
por parte de la otan que para que como
mínimo ucrania tenga los medios
tecnológicos para derrotar
definitivamente a rusia y quizá
bombardear la en su territorio
de ucrania nos vamos a reino unido el
ataúd de la reina isabel segunda fue
trasladado desde el palacio real de
holyroodhouse
hasta la catedral de saint gilles la
iglesia más importante de edimburgo y de
toda escocia el cortejo fúnebre estuvo
liderado por el rey carlos tercero y por
sus hermanos la princesa habana el duque
de york andrés y el conde de wessex
edward el féretro permanecerá en capilla
ardiente por 24 horas antes de ser
trasladado a londres el informe es de
manuela caro
el recorrido comenzó en el palacio
hollywood house
el rey carlos tercero encabezó la
procesión del ataúd de la reina isabel
por las calles de edimburgo en escocia
acompañado por la reina consorte camila
y miembros de la familia real como la
princesa anna y los príncipes and you
edward el cuerpo de la reina llegó a su
primera parada la catedral de saint
georges el camino estuvo marcado por la
solemnidad y la emoción de los
espectadores al lado y lado de la
carretera
tengo 47 años toda mi vida escuché sobre
esta increíble mujer no soy de aquí soy
de muy lejos pero para mí no es sólo tu
reina es mi reina también
amo a la reina como siempre lo he hecho
estaba muy molesta cuando murió me
enteré en la escuela hay muchas personas
de mi edad realmente no aprecian lo
mucho que ha hecho y lo duro que ha
trabajado
en medio de la emoción el ataúd fue
ingresado en la catedral allí
permanecerá durante 24 horas antes de
seguir su peregrinación hasta londres la
familia real la primera ministra de
escocia nicola sturgeon y la primera
ministra británica listos entre otros
presenciaron una ceremonia íntima y
suntuosa en la que el negro de los
vestidos de los asistentes contrastó con
las luces del lugar y donde se entonó el
himno nacional
[Música]
el acto también estuvo lleno de
simbolismo como la corona de escocia
colocada sobre el ataúd de la reina a
las afueras el ambiente es diferente las
largas filas de los seguidores de la
monarca marcan el panorama de edimburgo
en estas deberán esperar varias horas
para poder entrar a la catedral allí se
espera que miles de personas desfilen
para darle un último adiós a la monarca
además de estar en escocia para
acompañar el traslado del ataúd el rey
carlos tercero llegó a edimburgo para
asistir a su primera sesión del
parlamento escocés como monarca
vistiendo una falda típica del país
carlos tercero le dijo a los
parlamentarios que su madre había
encontrado un refugio y un hogar en
escocia y prometió asumir sus nuevos
deberes como rey velando siempre por el
bienestar común con el asistido su
esposa y la reina consorte camila ambos
fueron recibidos por la ministra
principal escocesa nicola sturgeon quien
después de un minuto de silencio en el
parlamento inició la moción de
condolencias posteriormente el rey
viajará a irlanda del norte y a gales
antes de llegar al funeral de la reina
isabel segunda en londres
presidente es primer ministro líderes de
partidos y miembros del parlamento
escocés kris balones
sé que el parlamento escocés y el pueblo
de escocia comparten conmigo un profundo
sentimiento de dolor por la muerte de mi
amada madre rif artes me laven mal
a lo largo de todos los años a su
reinado
like ser
la reina como tantas generaciones de
nuestra familia antes que ella encontró
en las colinas de esta tierra y en el
corazón de su gente un refugio y un
hogar
este lunes cerró la sesión 76 de la
asamblea general de naciones unidas
mientras que la sesión número 77 se
abrirá el martes con la posición del
nuevo presidente de la asamblea el
húngaro saba coros y por otra parte
aunque en su discurso inicial el
secretario de naciones unidas antonio
guterres priorización la guerra nuclear
ya varios activistas de afganistán están
intentando que lo que ocurre en este
país no quede en el olvido en especial
la muy difícil situación de las mujeres
el informe es de marina sardina
un llamado de atención al mundo sobre la
situación de las afganas previo al
cierre de la sesión de las 76 asamblea
general de naciones unidas activistas
afganas en el exilio alzaron la voz para
denunciar las violaciones de los
derechos que padecen las mujeres y niñas
en afganistán desde la toma del poder de
los talibanes en agosto de 2021 y
reclaman acciones internacionales firmes
contra el gobierno ladies and gentlemen
lo que está ocurriendo en afganistán
señoras y señores es una parte de género
claramente una parte de género no soy la
primera en decirlo pero la inacción de
la comunidad internacional y de los
responsables en la toma de decisiones en
general hace que sea importante que
todos nosotros lo repitamos afganistán
es una parte de género gender a first
time la guerra en ucrania la inflación
mundial o la crisis de alimentos ha
copado las reuniones del último año en
nueva york' relegando a afganistán a un
segundo plano mientras los talibanes sin
cumplían sus promesas respecto a las
mujeres finalmente han quedado recluidas
en sus hogares sin poder acceder a la
educación trabajar y obligadas a
ocultarse bajo el burka en great lakes
estoy profundamente preocupado por la
asombrosa regresión en el disfrute de
los derechos civiles
los económicos sociales y culturales de
mujeres y niñas desde que los talibanes
tomaron el control del country según
naciones unidas unas 850.000 niñas se
han visto forzadas a abandonar la
escuela quedando en riesgo de ser
sometidas a matrimonios forzados a la
explotación económica o sexual
entretanto el gobierno talibán sigue
pidiendo un reconocimiento hasta ahora a
la comunidad internacional de niega las
autoridades mexicanas se reunieron hoy
en ciudad de méxico con el secretario de
estado de eeuu anthony blinken y con la
secretaria de comercio de la casa blanca
jim a raymundo la delegación mexicana
dice que el llamado diálogo económico de
alto nivel se centrará en los
semiconductores las telecomunicaciones y
la medicina la mayor discusión es el
control estatal del mercado energético
pues mientras el presidente de andrés
manuel lópez obrador defiende que es
cuestión de soberanía la reforma que
priorizaría la generación de energía a
través de la estatal comisión federal de
electricidad eeuu considera que ésta
viola el acuerdo comercial que tienen
los tres países norteamericanos
por su parte blinken afirmo que el
proceso de solución de controversias
continuará
españa vive un repunte de violencia
entre integrantes de las llamadas bandas
juvenil juveniles violentas que
surgieron en los primeros años del siglo
21 en el país el perfil de los
pandilleros ha ido cambiando pero la
problemática de raíz sigue siendo la
misma soledad desarraigo o carencias
afectivas y familiares mientras la
policía se esfuerza en prevenir que los
jóvenes entren a estos grupos las
iglesias se convierten en la única
opción de salir de ellas sin
repercusiones el siguiente informe lo
preparo nuestra corresponsal de madrid
marina colorado
ahora caminan juntos pero hasta hace
unos años estos jóvenes no podían estar
en un mismo lugar artur pertenecía a los
'latin kings' jenny a los trinitarios
dos de las grandes bandas juveniles
violentas que existen en españa eran
enemigos pero con historias similares
bueno en este momento yo necesitaba lo
que era un apoyo familiar y mi padre era
maltratador y mi madre trataba de darme
lo mejor pero yo yo me sentía abandonado
y yo cogí un refugio en ello de poderme
esconder de poderme sentir apoyados de
mis padres había muchas peleas
entonces en casa ya no me sentía bien yo
prefería estar fuera de casa entonces
fue allí cuando yo les conocía
vamos a hacer tu familia entraron a
estas bandas con 14 y 13 años
respectivamente
ahora la edad de inicio es cada vez más
temprana por eso la policía nacional
enfoca sus esfuerzos de prevención en
las escuelas
hablando del alumnado a los padres
a los profesores contándoles la realidad
del problema que es pertenecer ingresar
o simplemente simpatizar con algún tipo
de banda juvenil en el cual puede
destrozar prácticamente una vida y toda
la de su entorno
jenny y artur salieron de estos grupos
violentos bajo el amparo de la iglesia
una de las pocas opciones de escape que
no trae consigo represalias
cuando tienen problemas
y son presos que les visita es un pastor
es un sacerdote hay un respeto ellos
saben que cuando necesitan ayuda pueden
venir de hecho nos buscan jóvenes que
son miembros activos de bandas para
desahogarse esta iglesia ha ayudado a
unos 300 jóvenes a desvincularse de la
violencia sin embargo sólo en madrid hay
unos 2500 pandilleros activos un negocio
que además mueve casi 10 millones de
euros anuales
falleció a los 96 años el fotógrafo
estadounidense william klein su mayor
legado es un innovador estilo de retrato
que influyó la moda y la fotografía en
1954 incursionó como fotógrafo luego de
conocer a alexander liberman el director
artístico de box line también fue
cineasta con obras dedicadas a la
industria de la moda o la guerra en
vietnam
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con
nosotros
[Música]